maly ist 2012 ins chaos gestürzt
derzeit laufen sieben internationale
missionen um das land bei der rückkehr
zur demokratie zu unterstützen und für
sicherheit zu sorgen
ein mühsames unterfangen heute in vechta
kompakt mali 1 vergessene konflikt der
konflikt mit den torreigen norden des
riesigen landes flammten seit der
unabhängigkeit 1960 immer wieder auf
zuletzt im jahr 2012 damals herrschte
chaos in der hauptstadt bamako infolge
eines unblutigen militärputsch es nur
eine internationale intervention unter
französischer führung konnte den
weiteren vorstoß der touareg nach bamako
stoppen durch die region war nachhaltig
destabilisieren
in nord mali wurde sogar ein eigener
staat ausgerufen dschihadistische
gruppen wie al-qaida oder anzahl den
erlangten neben diversen turek stimmen
immer mehr einfluss in nord mali und
konnten sogar einige städte unter ihre
kontrolle bringen
2015 wurde im friedensabkommen mit den
gruppierungen des nordens geschlossen
aber unter ausschluss wesentliche
akteure nach den zahlreichen
kampfhandlungen in nord mali haben sich
die bewaffneten auseinandersetzungen
seit 2016 zunehmend nach zentralen mali
verlagert doch nachbarstaaten und
internationale organisationen wie die
afrikanische union die uno und die eu
haben großes interesse an einem stabilen
mal
wesentliche gründe dafür sind
verhinderung der ausbreitung des
konfliktes in der region bekämpfen
radikal islamistischer kräfte
sie sollen keinen rückzugsraum wie
damals in afghanistan vorfinden
eindämmung von schmuck und migration
stärkung der staates mali als partner
daher auch unterstützung der politischen
und wirtschaftlichen reformen sowie
wiederherstellung von frieden und
sicherheit und es bestehen spezifische
interessen einzelner länder
daher gab es seit 2003 10 8
internationale einsätze in mali mit
unterschiedlichen zielsetzungen sieben
davon laufen
im sommer 2018 nach frankreich ist als
ehemalige kolonialmacht besonders
engagiert und hat eine führende rolle
schon seit 2013 gibt es die un mission -
mal die auch zum einsatz militärischer
gewalt ermächtigt ist mit etwa 13.000
mann soll sie das
waffenstillstandsabkommen überwachen die
sicherheit von zivilisten gewährleisten
und allgemein sicherheit herstellen
die afrikanische union führt die zivile
mission michael durch hauptaufgabe ist
es den politischen prozess im land zu
unterstützen und maßnahmen in der region
zu koordinieren
eine rein französische operation zur
terrorbekämpfung ist back an den 4500
soldaten sind auf die sahel region
verteilt und ein drittel davon befindet
sich in mali weiters wurde im sommer
2017 auf initiative frankreichs die
aufstellung einer gemeinsamen
militärischen einheit von 15 staaten
beschlossen die etwa 5000 mann starke
truppe soll die strategischen interessen
dieser staaten sicherstellen und vor
allem nahe der staatsgrenzen eingesetzt
werden
die eu betreibt drei missionen mal seit
2013 die trainingsmission tm für die
malische armee seit 2015 eine zivile
mission zum kapazitätsaufbau für
sicherheitsorgane und seit 2017 eine
stabilisierungsmission mit knapp einem
dutzend beratern
österreich nimmt derzeit mit zwölf
soldaten an der eu trainingsmission und
mit maximal vier an der un-mission teil
wie ist das internationale engagement
einzuschätzen wesentliche merkmale sind
ein umfassender ansatz der zivile und
militärische elemente enthält
der einsatz ist nicht das land mali
begrenzungen es wird die gesamte region
einbezogen
es erfolgt eine koordinierte
zusammenarbeit von kräften der region
der afrikanischen union der eu und der
uno der aufbau malischer kapazitäten
folgt dem motto viel
zur selbsthilfe die zielsetzungen und
erwartungen sind den realen
möglichkeiten angepasst damit sollten
überzogene erwartungen und
enttäuschungen wie in afghanistan
vermieden werden können
bewertung und ausblick die
präsidentschaftswahlen im sommer 2008
zehn konnten zwar aus sicherheitsgründen
nicht in allen teilen des landes
abgehalten werden durch deshalb ist das
internationale krisen management
keinesfalls als gescheitert zu sehen
denn es ist in mali gelungen eine
machtübernahme durch radikale und
extremistische kräfte zu verhindern
den friedensprozess zu beleben und die
weichen für eine positive entwicklung
des landes zu stellen
der konflikt markt zwar aus den
schlagzeilen verschwunden sein
die internationale aufmerksamkeit ist
jedoch geblieben
[Musik]